الله اكبر
روح روح روح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حياتك
[موسيقى]
اذا معنى الان جمعه كاس مراسل العربيه عبر
سكايت من القامشلي ومعنا كذلك موفد
العربيه الى اسطنبول غسان ابو اللوز على
امل ان يكون معنا بعد قليل ايضا زيدان
زنكلو من اضنه
ابدا معك غسان اخر المعطيات
وفق تركيا الرسميه فيما يتعلق بعمليات
الانقاذ وابرز
الاحتياجات التركيه
بالفعل ما
زالت داخليه التركي قال قبل ساعه تقريبا
ان 48 ساعه المقبله هي ساعه حاسمه ومهمه
جدا في عمليات الانقاذ وبالتالي العمليات
مستمره
ومتواصله رغم الظروف الجويه القاسيه جدا
جدا طاهر هناك عاصفه زنجيه تضرب البلاد
نحن خرجنا من اسطنبول منذ تقريبا اربع
ساعات ومتجهين الى انقره ومن ثم الى
الجنوب حيث المناطق التي تضررت بالكاد
نستطيع السير بسبب يعني هطول الثلوج بشكل
كثيف جدا وهذا ما تواجهه ايضا قوافل
المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ التي تحاول الوصول
الى تلك المناطق عبر هذه الطرقات والظروف
الجويه صعبه هيك عن الطرقات اللي في مناطق
الجنوب التي تعرضت لاضرار لكن تحاول
السلطات هناك دائما ايجاد طرق بديله لوصول
طواقم الانقاذ بعد يعني فرق المساعدات
الدوليه التي وصلت تعذر عليها ايضا من
الوصول الى تلك المناطق نتيجه الظروف
الجويه السيئه لكن العمل ما زال جاريا
لايصال تلك الفرق بشكل متواصل
والتعامل مع هذه الكارثه غير المسبوقه في
تاريخ البلاد تركيا والمنطقه كما وصفها
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اليوم في كلمه له
وقال بان الوضع صعب وايضا توقع بان يرتفع
عدد القتلى بشكل اكبر من ذلك بكثير وايضا
عدد الاصابات وشاهدنا هذا خلال خلال ساعات
ارتفع عدد المصابين الى نحو 27 الف اصابه
وايضا عدد لتجاوز ال 4500 قتيل في تركيا
ويتوقع ان يرتفع وتكون هناك قفزات في عدد
القتلى وعدد المصابين هناك سلطات تمكنت من
انتشال ميازيد عن 8,000 شخص حتى هذه
اللحظه وما زالت العمليات مستمره لكن كما
اشرنا هناك صعوبات تواجه سواء كانت من
الظروف الجويه السيئه جدا او من المخاوف
المستمره والمتواصله من
اهتزازات ارضيه ارتداديه تضرب المنطقه
هناك عشرات الاهتزازات التي تم رصدها قبل
قليل كان هناك حديث عن هزه ارضيه
بخمس يعني خمس درجات
في
كهرمان
وبالتالي هو هذا ابرز تخشاه السلطات
التركيه هنا في المناطق الجنوبيه حيث مركز
الزلزال طاهر وبالتالي
العمليات متواصله الرئيس قال ان هناك
اربعه 54 الف خيمه تم تجهيزها لتوجيها الى
المناطق المنسوبه ايضا هناك 5000 عامل في
قطاع الصحه ارسلوا الى هناك وايضا وزير
الدفاع التركي قال بان هناك تقريبا 200
مستشفى ميداني تم ارسالها الى تلك المناطق
وهذا يشير الى حجم الكارثه الكبير الذي
تعاني منه تركيا
تتحدث عن ان الطرق التي تؤدي الى المناطق
المنكوبه متضرره بشده هل هي متضرره بشده
لدرجه ان طواقم الانقاذ او حتى التواقم
الطبيه والمساعدات لا تستطيع العبور
والوصول الى المناطق المتضرره ام انها
مقطوعه بشكل كامل
راويه ليست مقطوعه بشكل كامل يعني هناك
سلطات تعاملت مع اجزاء من الطرق حيث يعني
استطاعوا ترميم اجزاء من تلك الطرق لتسهيل
تسهيل قوافل المساعدات فرق الانقاذ لكنها
متضرره وهي تؤثر بشكل كبير على حركه السير
لذلك هناك دعوات من السلطات التركيه
للمدنيين والمواطنين بعدم التوجه المناطق
حتى لا يكون هناك
ازمات سير في تلك الطريق وفتح الطريق طرق
امام قوافل المساعدات ما لاحظناه في
طريقنا راويه ونحن نمشي الان هناك العديد
من المواطنين يحملون مركباتهم الخاصه
بالمياه
والاغطيه ويتجهون الى المناطق الجويه
الجنوبيه رغم ظروف الجويه الصعبه ورغم وضع
الطرق في تلك المناطق لكنهم يريدون
تقديم المساعده وما يمكن تقديمه لاهالي
المناطق الجنوبيه المنكوبه هناك يعني حديث
ان السلطات التركيه استقبلت اكثر من 100
الف طلب من الشباب والشابات الاتراك لتطوع
في عمليات المساعده مع انهم ليس لديهم اي
خبره في
الاجازه لكن الوضع بهذا السوء يستدعي
استقبال هذه الطلبات للتعامل مع هذا الدرس
هناك اكثر من 60 الف مشارك في عمليات
الانقاذ من سواء كان حكومي او غير ذلك من
منظمات المجتمع المدني والهلال الاحمر
التركي
هناك ايضا فرص المساعدات والانقاذ
الاجنبيه والغربيه التي تصل تباعا الى
تركيا
تقريبا 65
دوله
كمان انهم قدموا مبادره للمساعده في تركيا
في هذا الظرف الاستثنائي والكارثي الذي
تمر فيه البلاد قد نعود اليك سنه بلوز
مفرد العربيه الى اسطنبول وانت في طريقك
الى المناطق المتضرره شكرا جزيلا على
الكره هذه المعلومات للان من القامشلي عبر
سكايب مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش الان جمعه
اهلا بك اخر التفاصيل التي وردتك حول
عمليات الانقاذ
دخول المساعدات
مرحبا طاهر بك براوي ابو ساده المشاهدين
عمليات الانقاذ منذ صباحا اليوم كانت تشهد
وتيره
متسارعه يعني الاستثمار في الوقت المتبقي
وانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من الضحايا على تحت
الارض
تقريبا الاربعين الماضيه منذ بدء
الزلزال يعني جهود
الاغاث او فرق لانقاذ نجحت بانتشال حوالي
450 شخص في عموم الجغرافيا السوريه
وتحديدا في المناطق المنكوبه من تحت الارض
لكن هذا لم يضع حدا
الماساه لا حيث لا يزال اكثر من يعني
المئات المئات من الاشخاص تحت الانقاض بدء
الوقت يعني يمضي عليهم
ويقلص فرص العثور عليهم احياء الصيام وانا
البقاء تحت هذه في ظل ظروف
المنائز ظروف الطقس القاسيه وايضا الجوع
والعطش اضافه الى الرعب الذي يعنوه قد
يقلص من فرص يعني بقائهم
احياء في في المناطق في في مدينه حماه
يعني اعلنت الجهات المعنيه انتهاء عمليات
ازاله الالقاد وانتهاء عمليات البحث عن
ناجين بعد انتشال 43 جثه في مبنى واحد
بينما في مدينه اللاذقيه يعني الجهود
مكثفه تشارك فيها فرق انقاذ مختصه قدمت
منها الجزائر واخرى من
لبنان اضافه الى مشاركه من عناصر من الجيش
الروسي لكن الوضع يبدو قاتم وماساوي حيث
المهمه منوطه فقط بالدفاع المدني في مناطق
المعارضه الى جانب مجموعه من الشباب
المتطوعين الذين يستخدمون اليات بسيطه
وبدايه لرفع الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجين
المحتمرين بين ركائن المنازل الجمعه
معبر باب الهوى على الحدود التركيه
السوريه بان المعبر متاح لتوصيل المساعدات
هل هناك من تاكيد على الارض ان كان متاحا
وبدا باستقبال المساعدات عبر
نعم كنا صباح اليوم نؤكد بان المعبر مفتوح
عندما انتشرت يعني معلومات بين مغلق
المعبر مفتوح لم ينظر اي قرار رسمي لا من
تركيا ولا من المعارضه السوريه باغلاق
المعبر لكن المعبر غير مفعل لسببين الاول
الطرق المؤديه اليهم من الولايات في تركيا
المتضرره اصبحت يعني غير في اجزاء يعني
واسعه منها ثانيا المساعدات اصلا لم تاتي
الى هذا المعبر ولم يتم ايضا حتى نقل يعني
جرحى او مصابين الى داخل اراضي التركيه
عبر المعبر الا حالات تعاد على اصابع اليد
لذلك المعبر هو غير مفعل لكنه غير مغلق
بقرار
يعني تضرر بفعل الزلزال كما تقول
المعلومات وكما افدتنا قبل قليل
ويعني ع لاوه على ذلك انه بعض كثير من
الموظفي الامم المتحده الذين هم يعني منوط
بهم القيام باعمال كثيره في هذه الاوضاع
هم من المتضررين اصلا يبحثون عن اهاليهم
في بعض منهم
صحيحه يا طاهر يعني عدد كبير من العمال
الاغاثه والعاملين في المنظمات المحليه
التي تعمل كشريك على الارض لمفوضيه سوالب
مفوضيه او للهلال الاحمر او لصليب الاحمر
الدوليين متضررون يعني حتى بالكثير من
الصحفيون الذين يعني نحاول التواصل معهم
لتدقيق او تمحيص او اضافه بعض يبحثون عن
اهلهم ويتقطعت بهم
السبل يعني حتى زميلنا زيدان كان لديه
يعني انقطاع عن والدته واخته في غازي
عنتاب يعني هذه الحاله عامه تشمل الكادر
الطبي عمال الاغاثه عمال المنظمات وحتى
يعني القطاع الطبي وهذا ايضا طبعا يعقد
يعني المشكله اكثر مما هي عليه خاصه في
المناطق
سواء في سوريا او تركيا شكرا لك حتى
الساعه جمعه كاش من القامشلي مراسل
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تعرف تلعب العاب
احسن منك
اذا جبت شو
طالعين
[موسيقى]
وصلتنا هاي البنت امبارح الساعه ثلاثه
الظهر مع كدمات عديده ومع ساحجات كامل
جسمها البنت وجتنا كمان بازيه برد البنت
شديد تم تطفيء طاقه كالسيوم اعطائها سكر
ووضع
[موسيقى]
وجه العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجهها مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه بتسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا
وسوريا وبالاضافه الى تقديم مساعدات صحيه
وايوائيه وغذائيه لتخفيف اثار الزلزال
الذي ستنطلق اعتبارا من يوم غد كما وجه
الملك سلمان والامير محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم
حمله شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم لمساعده ضحايا
الزلزال
اكد سامر الجطيلي المتحدث باسم مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه ان
الجسر الجوي الموجه لاغاثه سوريا وتركيا
سيوفر امدادات مهمه للمتضررين من الزلزال
تشمل مواعيد تشمل الكثير من الاغذيه
والخييم للاواء فضلا عن مستلزمات طبيه
مركز الملك سلمان وضع الخطه
لتدخل الانساني عاجل يركز على الاحتياجات
الاساسيه خلال المرحله الاوليه مرحله
التدخل الاولي او ما يسمى بالتدخل
الانساني العاجل
هذه المرحله سوف تشمل الحقيقه تقديم
سلام غذائيه او الحقيقه الحرص كل الحرص
على تامين الاحتياجات في مجال القطاع
الغذائي كذلك القطاع الاخر هو اولويه قصوى
هو قط
[موسيقى]
اع ميمي الخيام وكذلك
الحقيبه الايوائيه المعياريه التي يقدمها
عاده مركز الملك سلمان خلال هذه الازمات
هناك كذلك اهتمام كبير جدا بالاحتياجات في
المجال الطبي تامين الاحتياجات سواء كانت
من ادويه او سواء الوريديه او غيرها
تشد الاحتياج تساعد الحقيقه في نوعا ما
تامين الاستقرار للحاله الصحيه الى
المتضررين في هذه الفتره
ومن خسائر ينضم الينا عدنان ابو حسناء
المستشار الاعلامي لوكاله غوت وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين اهلا بك سيد عدنان
يعني هل توفرت ارقام تقريبيه حتى الان حول
يعني المفقودين من اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
المتواجدين في الاراضي المتضرره او
المناطق المتضرره على الجانب السوري ان
كان ضحايا المفقودين
نعم بصراحه ما حدث يعني حدث كبير
وجلل يعني حتى الان الجهود تبذل لايجاد
العشرات من اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
المفقودين ولكن هناك انباء تتحدث حتى الان
عن وجود يرمان نعرفه نحن في المخيمات
مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الاربعه التي
يقتلها حوالي 62 الف لاجئ منهم 58 الف
تضرروا من هذا الزلزال هناك ايضا لاجئين
فلسطينيين من الجانب التركي ولكن نحن
نتعامل مع مخيمات اللاجئين التي يمكن
الوسطبل لها من دمشق لانه سوريا دوله
مضيفه للذين الفلسطينيين الحاجات كبيره
هناك مفقودون بلا بلا شك وارقام
القتلى في الجانبين من هنا ومن هناك
كفلسطينيين اكثر من 60 شخص حتى الان حسب
احصاءات السلطه الفلسطينيه الفلسطيني
الموجود في تركيا والموجود ايضا في سوريا
وكما عرفنا استاذ عدنان انه ايضا هناك من
لجا بفعل التضرر في مناطقه الى هذه
المخيمات يعني ممن لم يكونوا في المخيمات
وقد تضرروا كم الاعداد وما هي حاجيات
الاساسيه كم تستطيعون الصمود بما توفر لكم
من
اموال ومن مواد غذائيه وطبيه
يعني على سبيل المثال حوالي 700 لاجئ
فلسطين لجاوا الى مدارس ومنشات الاونروا
في منطقه اللاذقيه ولكن نحن نتحدث عن 58
الف لاجئ فلسطيني
تضرروا الامكانيات هي امكانيات بسيطه بلا
شك نحن اعلنا باننا بحاجه الى 72 مليون
دولار تقريبا ثلاثه ملايين دولار لتغطيه
حاجات اساسيه تتحدث عن فراش القيام
بطانيات مواد غذائيه لدينا فعلا نحن في
مخازن مواد طبيه وبدانا في توزيعها ولكن
هذه المواد فتنسى يعني ستنفذ حساب الحجم
يعني بالنهايه كمنظمه امميه يعني قد
يستغرق الامر عده اسابيع او اقل يعني
المخزون لم يكن لمخزونا بحجم هذه الكارثه
الكبرى التي اصابت المنطقه بس ثلاث ملايين
دولار يعني
تقدير نعم هذا تقدير مبدئي نحن نتحدث الان
عن مساعدات عاجله تتعلق باساس اساسيه
تتعلق بالطعام تتعلق بالفراش بالاغطيه
بالتدفئه يعني امور بسيطه للغايه ولكن بعد
ذلك سيتم تطوير هذا النداء طيب سيد عدنان
يعني التنسيق مع الجهات ان كانت الرسميه
السوريه او المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
المعارضه السوريه على اي مستوى يحصل يعني
على اي نقاط يتم الحديث والتنسيق
هناك تنسيق كبير مع الدوله السوريه لانه
سوريا هي الدوله المضيفه يعني تتحرك نحن
تحت حمايه ورعايه الدوله السوريه ولكن
بالنسبه لاجئين الفلسطينيين الموجودين في
الجانب او المناطق التي تسيطر عليها تركيا
او وما الى ذلك والتي لا نستطيع الوصول
اليها هناك منظمات امميه عديده كل منظمات
اللي هو المتحده تعمل الان في تلكون معها
لا نحن ننسق بصراحه في الجانب السوري الذي
مع الحكومه السوريه ولكن هناك هناك مفوضيه
نعم هناك المفوضيه العليا اللاجئين الصحه
العالميه اليونيسف الجميع يعمل في تلك
المناطق
هل يمكن يعني الى ماذا يمكن ان تلعبوا
دورا
في الداخل السوري في العلاقه مع المنظمات
الاوروبيه والامريكيه والدوليه التي لا
تزال لا تتعامل مع يعني كحكومات اقصد لا
تزال تتعامل مع النظام ولكن ستمرر كل شيء
عبر المنظمات هل لكم دور في هذا الاطار
نعم نحن على اتصال يعني نحن اصلا ميزانيه
من الدول المانحه ليس مهما علاقه او غير
علاقه نحن منظمه امميه تعمل بتفويض لخدمه
438 الف لاجئ فلسطيني في مناطق الدوله
السوريه هناك الاف وعشرات الالاف في
المناطق الخارجه عن سيطره الدوله السوريه
ولكن نحن نتعامل مع دول المانحه نتعامل مع
المنظمات امميه منظمات حكوميه وغير امميه
ولا نجد حرجا والامور يعني لا نجد فيها
صعوبات كثيره الدوله السوريه تتفهم بوضع
الاونروا يعني لا نجد عقبات في العمل في
سوريا يعني يمكن ان تقوموا بمثل هذا الدور
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد يعني نحن نشدنا المجتمع
الدولي بان يقدم لنا خدمات يقدم لنا
تمويلا عاجلا وبعد هذا التمويل سيكون هناك
تمويل اخر وتطوير هذا النداء حتى تتضح
الصوره تماما يعني الان كل الفراق على
الارض تقيم ما الذي ما الذي حدث ولكن نحن
نؤكد بانه من 62 الف لاجئ فلسطيني موجودين
في اربع مخيمات في شمال سوريا هناك 58 الف
لاجئ تضرروا من هذا الزلزال يعني اتحدث
اكثر
58 الف متضرر فلسطيني ما اولوياتكم يعني
من اجل الدعم الذي تطلبونه
يعني الكل يعرف انه هذه المخيمات ايضا
اثناء الحرب السوريه تعرضت الى ضرر كبير
يعني مخيم النيرب يعني هو دمر والان جاء
الزلزال يدمر ما تبقى من هذا المخيم وبقيه
المخيمات الحاجات الاساسيه الان نتحدث عن
فراش عن اغنى ادويه عن مواد غذائيه ولكن
الحديث عن اعمار المخيمات هذا سياخذ وقتا
طويلا ويحتاج الى تمويل اكبر ولكن نعم
اليوم نحن نتحدث عن انقاذ هؤلاء الناس عن
تقديم مساعدات اوليه له شو طبيعه التضرر
اللي صار ل58 الف استاذ عدنان
لن نتحدث عن مئات البيوت التي تضررت على
المنشات الاونروا ايضا التي اصيبت باضرار
كبيره يعني في النهايه في على سبيل المثال
في اللاذقيه في مخيم اللاذقيه الناس لم
تجد الى اين تذهب فذهبوا الى احد مدارس
الاونروا وهذه اعاده وتكرار لتجربه غزه
يعني استخدام المدارس
كمالاجئ ويتم الان تقديم المساعدات
الاوليه
طيب سيد عدنان يعني البعض لجا الى مدارس
الاونروا التي هي ليست كثيره الباقون هل
من معلومات اين هم متواجدين هل من ماوى هل
من خيم تستضيفهم
لا حتى الان بصراحه لا يوجد مثل هذه
الاشياء ولكن البعض عند اقاربه بعض البيوت
دمرت جزئيا بعض الناس موجودين بها وهكذا
البعض ترك المنطقه الى مناطق اخرى ولكن
الغالبيه تنتظر المساعدات التي ستقدمها
الاونروا والدوله السوريه وغيرها من
المؤسسات هل هناك ايات وعود وصلتكم بشان
الحاجه للملايين الثلاثه الان
لا نحن اطلقنا اليوم اطلقنا اليوم هذا
النداء نتوقع خلال الساعات والايام
القادمه ان يكون هناك استجابه راينا يعني
نوع من الاجماع الدولي والحشد الدولي سواء
الاقليمي العربي او الحشد الدولي بالنسبه
لما حدث في تركيا وسوريا وهذا يعني شيء
جيد يسهل عمليات الحصول على التمويل نامل
ان نحصل على هذا التمويل في اسرع وقت
السيد عدنان سؤال اخير لحضرتك يعني هل
هناك
نيه لارسال كوادر بشريه ربما للمساعده
بعمليات الانقاذ ويعني او ربما القيام
بمسح شامل على الارض حول اوضاع اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين هل لديكم هذه القدره او النيه
القدره الماديه طبعا
نحن بالنسبه للطواقم طواقم الاونروا كلها
متواجده وتعمل على يعني لمساعده الناس في
هذا الاطار ولكن الحديث عن بنى تحتيه
متهالكه عن وضع اقتصادي صعب
والحرب السوريه التي دمرت دمرت الكثير
يعني هذا زلزال اضاف لمعاناه جديده غير لا
تستطيع بصراحه الاونروا القيام بهذا الدور
لوحده يجب ان يكون هناك
تجمع كبير سواء المنظمات الاماميه او غير
امميه ودول في الاقليم وغير الاقليم تعمل
لمواجهه هذه الماساه الكبرى التي تعرضت
لها سوريا شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عدنان ابو
حسنه مستشار العالمي لوكاله وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين من غزه تحياتنا اليك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله ياكل
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
قل لا اله الا الله
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التي مزقتها الحرب لسنوات ليست قادره
بالمره على تحمل تبعات زلزال قويه بهذا
الحجم وهو ما يزيد من تازم الاوضاع
الانسانيه داخل البلاد
اذا طاهر فالمنطقه الشماليه من سوريا التي
ضربها الزلزال تعاني اساسا من مشاكل
بنيويه كثيره فهذه المنطقه هي الاكثر
تضررا في سوريا بسبب الحرب وما صاحبها من
قصف جوي دمر المنازل والمستشفيات
والعيادات كما يعيش العديد من السوريين في
مبانئ متضرره اصلا كما تعاني هذه المنطقه
من ازمه اقتصاديه متفاقمه ادت الى نقص
الوقود وزياده انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
ونقص كبير في المواد الغذائيه ويعيش اساسا
في شمال سوريا حوالي اربعه ملايين شخص في
مخيمات كما يعتمدون على المساعدات عبر
الحدود لتامين حاجياتهم او الاولويه وحتى
قبل وقوع الزلزال فان عدد الاشخاص الذين
يحتاجون الى دعم انساني كان اكبر من اي
وقت مضى منذ بدء الحرب حيث يحتاج 70% من
السكان الى المساعده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا تنضم الينا من واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي
مراسله العربيه وايضا من باريس حسين قنيبر
مراسل العربيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك حسين
يعني ما هي الجهات او عبر اي مسارات تمر
المساعدات الفرنسيه المقرره لمساعده تركيا
اهلا بكما راويه وطاهر في الواقع هذه
المساعدات تتصل عبر اربعه مسارات وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الداخليه بلديه باريس
وايضا تحالف من 6 منظمات انسانيه فرنسيه
ولكن بالاضافه الى الى هذه المسارات
الاربعه فان هناك منظمات انسانيه فرنسيه
تعمل من خارج هذه الاطر تعمل على ايصال
المساعدات لسوريا ولتركيا لسوريا حصرا عبر
المنظمات الانسانيه
ولتركيا عبر الاجهزه الحكوميه الفرنسيه
وزير الداخليه جلال درمنا اوضح عندما سئل
عن وجهه هذه المساعدات قال انها حصرا
اجراءات تتعلق بمساعده تركيا ولكن هذا لا
يمنع ان منظمات انسانيه فرنسيه مثل اطباء
بلا حدود ومثل كار اف وايضا اطباء العالم
وكذلك اطر فرنسيه اخرى تعمل ضمن منظمات
امميه مثل يونيسف والصليب الاحمر الدولي
هذه الاطر تعمل على ايصال مساعدات مباشره
الى سوريا على سبيل المثال منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود اعلنت انها قدمت معدات طبيه وفرق
طبيه الى 23 مؤسسه صحيه في حلب وادلب
وجوارهما ويعني هذه المساعدات تتوزعت على
المستشفيات والعيادات والمستوصفات ايضا
المسؤول عن منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قال انه
المطلوب الان مساعدات دوليه على مستوى
الماساه الحاصله وبالاضافه الى 139 مسعفا
الذين توجهوا الليل امس الى تركيا ووصلوا
اليها صباح اليوم فقط وصل عشره عناصر
ينتمون الى المجموعه الفرنسيه للنجده من
الكوارث وهي مجموعه متخصصه في عمليات
الانقاذ انطلقوا من شمال فرنسا ووصلوا ظهر
اليوم الى غازي عنتاب في تركيا هؤلاء
متخصصون منذ عشرين عاما في النجده من
الكوارث وصلوا على متن طائره خاصه تحمل
معدات تستطيع تحديد مواقع الضحايا وتحمل
مولدات كهربائيه هذه الطائره الخاصه وصلت
الى غازي عنتاب وهي واحده من عده طائرات
فرنسيه وصلت خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضيه بالاضافه الى هذه الاطر طبعا
وزاره الخارجيه قالت انها تلبي طلب
المساعده الذي تقدمت به تركيا طلب
المساعده والدعم الذي طلبته التركيه من
الاسره الدوليه وكذلك اعلنت عمده باريس
انها ستحرك مساعدات ماليه عاجله لكل من
تركيا وسوريا اذا اطر رسميه حكوميه عبر
الخ والداخليه الفرنسيه ولكن اطر خارجه عن
هذه المساعدات الحكوميه يعني تنحصر
بالمنظمات الانسانيه الى سوريا تحديدا
تمام تبقى معنا حسين الى ناديه البلبيسي
الان مراسله العربيه في واشنطن الوكاله
الدوليه
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه ناديه
كانت اعلنت عن وصول فريقين غدا الى تركيا
للبدء بعمليات البحث والانقاذ والمساعده
وايصال كل المساعدات التي تم الوعد بها اي
تفاصيل اضافيه عما ستقدمه الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه في هذا الاطار
عن حجم المساعدات وعن اي مؤسسات اكثر منوط
بها تقديم هذه المساعدات امريكيه
وكاله التنميه الامريكيه هي ذراع وزاره
الخارجيه وهي الوكاله الرئيسه التي تقوم
بالفعل بتقديم المساعدات الان سواء كانت
لتركيا او الى الشمال السوري طبعا الوكاله
قالت بانها ارسلت فريق مكون من 161 عام
الاغاثه هؤلاء الاشخاص لديهم الخبره لديهم
التقنيات لديهم الاجهزه والمعدات الثقيله
التي يمكن ان تكشف عن اولئك الذين لا
يزالون تحت الانقاض وبالتالي هي التي تقوم
بعمليه التنظيم وعمليه التنسيق بين
الوكالات الاخرى والتحرك بشكل فوري لانه
كما تعرف هي مساله حياه او موت هذا جزء
وهي هي التي تمثل المساعدات الحكوميه لكن
ايضا هناك مساعدات اخرى تاتي عن طريق
المنظمات غير الحكوميه
رايناها في بعض حتى المقاطعات الصغيره في
مقاطعه
راينا ايضا دور للجيش الامريكي راويه
وايضا هناك
مساعدات الان يتم ارسالها الى السفاره
التركيه في العاصمه واشنطن ربما في النشر
القادمه سيكون مع بعض الصور من هذه
المساعدات التي يرسلها المواطنين
الامريكيين ناديه كان هناك منشدات ان كان
رسميه من الجانب السوري او حتى شعبيه من
عده جنسيات حول ضروره رفع الحصار
والعقوبات عن سوريا من الجانب الامريكي
ولو بصوره مؤقته يعني لتسهيل وصول
المساعدات بطريقه مباشره الى المتضررين هل
يعني الجانب الامريكي يلحظ هذه هذا الطرح
هذه نقطه مهمه واسمحي لي ان اوضحها لانه
الاداره ترى هي فقط دعايه من النظام
السوري كل العقوبات الامريكيه بما فيها
عقوبات قيصر دوما كانت تستهدف النظام
النظام موجود في دمشق وليس موجود في ادلب
وفي ريف شمال الغربي لسوريا الذي يخضع
للمعارضه السوريه حتى كل هذه العقوبات
دوما دوما كانت تستثني المساعدات
الانسانيه وهي عباره عن غذاء ودواء نحن
نتحدث عن كارثه انسانيه بحجم هذا الزلزال
المدمر الولايات المتحده منذ ان طبعا علمت
بالخبر كان هناك تنسيق اتصالات بين البيت
الابيض وزاره الدفاع وزاره الخارجيه تعهد
من الرئيس بايدن تعهد من الوزير بارسال كل
ما تستطيع ان تفعله لمساعده المنكوبين
بالتحديد في سوريا طبعا الاداره تعمل قالت
لنا وزاره الخارجيه عن طريق المؤسسات
الامميه المؤسسات الانسانيه الغير حكوميه
الموجوده في داخل سوريا موضوع الحصار الذي
يدعي النظام بانه لا يستطيع او بمسؤول
الامريكي كان هناك شعور بالاستياء في
الواقع لانه لا يوجد هناك فهم لما يحدث
على مدى سنوات من استهداف النظام بهذه
العقوبات على العكس اليوم اوروبا بالتحديد
كانت تطالب وزير الخارجيه الالماني كان
يطالب النظام بالسماح بدخول المساعدات
يمكن حتى ان يكون اسهل ان تدخل عن طريق
دمشق بدل ما ان تدخل عن طريق تركيا هناك
مطالبه امريكيه ايضا بفتح معبر باب الهوى
وهو معبر شريان رئيسي كانت تركيا تقفله
فمعظم الوقت وهو ضروري لدخول المساعدات
الانسانيه وكانت روسيا تعارض في مجلس
الامن حتى ان يبقى مفتوحا اذا الذي يعرقل
دخول المساعدات والنظام السوري حسب وجهه
نظر واشنطن وايضا روسيا الى حد ما الان
الحديث عن هذه الكارثه الانسانيه كيف يمكن
جميعا ان يساعد والمساعدات كما ذكرت قبل
قليل هي حكوميه بالدرجه الاولى هناك دور
للجيش الامريكي بفتح الجسر وبارسال كل فرق
الانقاذ التي لديها الخبره الكافيه ليس
فقط هنا في الولايات المتحده لكن ايضا في
زلزال الذي ايضا كان مدمر وباثار كارثيه
تستطيع بالفعل ان تساعد لكن كما تعرفين
وصعوبه بدخول الاراضي السوريه ربما الامر
مختلف بالنسبه لتركيا ما بعرف اذا في اي
اجواء اي معلومات عندك او عند حسين ايضا
فيما يتعلق بامكانيه العمل من الدول دائمه
العضويه في مجلس الامن على اعاده فتح كل
المعابر
بين تركيا وسوريا وليس فقط معبر باب
الهواء من المعروف انه وفق الاليه
المعتمده من مجلس الامن الدولي كان في
يعني سماح لاكثر من معبر ومن ثم حصل ضغوط
كبيره من قبل دمشق وموسكو للابقاء فقط على
معبر باب الهوى وحتى هو احيانا
يقفل واحيانا يفتح بناخذ حسين بدايه
نعم في الواقع فرنسا حتى الان لا تاتي على
اي ذكر لاي احتمال بايصال مساعدات انسانيه
عبر اي معبر الى الجهات السوريه الرسميه
وتركز يعني مثلا بيان الخارجيه الفرنسيه
يوم امس لم ياتي على ذكر سوريا في معرضي
تفصيله المساعدات التي سيصار الى ارسالها
ذكرت سوريا في مطلع البيان بسطر واحد فقط
من باب التعبير عن الاسى لما حصل في كل من
تركيا وسوريا ولكن عندما بدا البيان يفصل
وجهه المساعدات ذكرت تركيا عده مرات لكن
هذا لا يحجب ابدا اهتمام المنظمات
الانسانيه الفرنسيه التي ذكرتها ولا يحجب
ايضا واقع ان المساعدات لا تنحصر بباريس
وحدها فهناك هيئات اهليه وبلديه
وانسانيه تعمل عبر فرنسا كلها ارسلت مساعد
من منطقه في الشمال الفرنسي ومن منطقه
البريطاني في الغرب الفرنسي وايضا من
منطقه النورماندي في الشمال الغربي
بالاضافه الى العاصمه الفرنسيه التي تحركت
فيها عده هيئات انسانيه وقوى شعبيه
باختصار ليست المساعدات الحكوميه وحدها هي
التي تحدد ما اذا كانت سترسل الى تركيا او
الى تركيا وسوريا وانما خارج الاطر
الحكوميه عدد كبير من الهيئات بدا ينشط
لتنظيم عمليات تطوع ولتنشيط عمليه ارسال
مبالغ ماليه الى سوريا فرق انقاذ وفرق
اطفاء ايضا وفرق متخصصه في عمليات البحث
عن ضحايا ومن ضمنها الفرقه المتخصصه التي
غادرت مطار لوتوكيه في الشمال الفرنسي على
متن طائره خاصه وعلى متنها معدات لتحديد
مواقع الضحايا كل هذا يحصل خارج الاطر
الحكوميه طاهر
نادي عند اي اجواء في هذا الموضوع اذا سئل
احد من المسؤولين عن هذا الموضوع عموما
يعني تاكيدا على ما كنت تقولينه قبل قليل
اليوم سفير النظام السوري لدى الامم
المتحده بسام صباغ بعد لقائه
قال ان الوصول الى داخل سوريا من داخل
سوريا متاح ومن يرغب بمساعده سوريا
بامكانه التنسيق مع الحكومه ونحن سنكون
على استعداد للقيام بذلك ناديه
هناك مناشده امريكيه في الواقع بالتحديد
لفتح كل المعابر وكما ذكرت كوتيلش نفسه
كان قد طالب النظام السوري وطلبه تركيا
حتى بالسماح بدخول بتسهيل السماح بالدخول
المساعدات للمنكوبين طبعا هناك تعقيدات
بدون ان سياسيه وجغرافيه
وسلامه الوصول حتى للطواقم وخصوصا بالنسبه
للامريكيين الذين لا يعملون لا يوجد وجود
يعني مدني امريكي في شمال سوريا هناك وجود
عسكري لاسباب مختلفه لكن اعتقد بان
الاداره ستعمل
ستحاول الضغط في مجلس الامن في الواقع لان
يكون هناك تسهيل لدخول هذه كل هذه
المساعدات وبالدرجه الاولى هي تضع يعني
لوم على نظام السوري تقول بانه بامكان
النظام السوري ان يعمل مع بعض المنظمات
الامميه لكنه هذا النظام الذي قام بقتل
شعبي وهذا اقتبس من نيد برايس بالامس
عندما قال بانه النظام يتحمل مسؤولي كبيره
لذا كانت هذه العقوبات التي فرضت على
النظام السوري بالتحديد لكن اعتقد باننا
سنرى ربما خطوات على الارض خلال فتره
قصيره بسبب الحاجه الملحه هذه الصوره
المؤثره جدا التي يراها العالم واعتقد انه
يكون هناك تحرك دولي امريكي وفي الاخبار
العاجله ايضا يعني في نفس السياق اللي عم
تتحدث عنها حيث المبعوثه الاوروبي لسوريا
دعا جميع الاطراف لفتح المعابر الحدوديه
الاغاثه المتضررين والمفوضيه الاوروبيه
ايضا اعلنت ارسال 28 فريقا الى تركيا
للمشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ نشكركما نادي
البلبيسي مراسلات العربيه من واشنطن وايضا
من باريس حسين قنيبر شكرا لكما
يظهر حجم الاضرار والخسائر التي خلفها
الزلزال يظهر كل ذلك مدى قوته فما الذي
يفسر سبب قوه زلزال عن غيره من الناحيه
العلميه الزلزال بلغت قوته
7.8 درجات وقد يعتقد البعض ان الفارق بين
ست درجات وسبع درجات مثلا ليس كبيرا لكن
الحقيقه ان الدرجه الكامله على مقياس
ريختر تعني عشره اضعاف القوه ايضا كان
الزلزال قريبا من سطح الارض حيث نشا على
عمق 18
فقط من السطح هذا يعني ان الموجات
الزلزاليه انتقلت بسرعه الى السطح ما ادى
الى اهتزازات حاده كما ان مركز الزلزال
وقع بالقرب من مدن وقرى ماهوله بالسكان ما
يفسر الاعداد الكبيره من الوفيات والجرحى
ومن بين العوامل الاخرى المؤثره كثره
الهزات الارتداديه التي تجاوز عددها
المئات ورغم ان الهزات الارتداديه ليست
بنفس قوه الهزات الرئيسيه او الزلزال
الرئيسي الا انها تعرقل عمليات الانقاذ
كما تتسبب في المزيد من الحطام خاصه
للمباني الاليله للسقوط التي تضررت من
الزلزال الاصلي
معنى من بيروت الان دكتور طوني الاستاذ
والباحث في الجيولوجيا وعلم الزلازل في
الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت اهلا بك معنا
دكتور
يعني معطياتك اللي خرجت فيها من كل
المعلومات التي توفرت حتى الان عن طبيعه
ومدى قوه هذا الزلزال مقارنه بما نعرف عن
الزلازل وعن هذه المنطقه تحديدا عن خط
الصدع هذا تحديدا
زلزال اتشلي حصل على
الاناضول الشرقي يلي هو
بيفصل الصفيحه العربيه عن الصفيحه
الاناضونيه حركه الزلزال هي بهيدا الشكل
حركه الفالق الاناضول الشرقي هو بهذا
الشكل
الصفيحتين العربيه والاناضويه ما عم بعده
عن بعضهم ولا عم بيقربوا لبعضهم عم
بيزيحوا بعضهم وهذا النوع من الزلازل هو
من من اقوى الانواع اللي هذا النوع من
الفوالق من اقوى من انواع التي يمكن يولد
زلازل كبيره كرمال هيك شفنا زلزال
هذه الضخامه طبعا
الفالق طويل جدا طوله حوالي 600 كم كل ما
كان فالك طويل كل مكان الانكسار بقشره
الارض طويله وكبيره كل مكان قوه الزلزال
اضخم وكرمال هيك شفنا للاسف هالدمار وهل
التاثير
بالجوار وكمان بعيد عنه دكتور يعني هذه
المنطقه معروف بانها معرضه للزلازل لكنها
لم تعرف منذ عقدين من الزمان حتى الان
زلزالا بهذه القوه هل يمكن ونحن نشاهد هذه
الصور فرق الانقاذ تحاول انقاذ
احياء ربما تحت الانقاض بمنطقه او ولايه
عثمانيه نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي ابقى معي
دكتور طوني
مشاهدينا العربيه ترصد في هذه الصور يا
طاهر محاولات فرق الانقاذ العثور على
ناجين تحت الانقاض تحديدا بمنطقه بولايه
بولايه عثمانيه بعد سماع اصوات الناجين
يعني اصوات الناجين هي اصوات الامل
للاهالي للاقارب دكتور طوني كنت اسالك عن
ان تشرح لنا نشاط هذه الصدوع تحديدا صدع
شرق الاناضول ما الذي يميزه
صدع شرق الانا اللي بيفصل بين الصفيحه
العربيه والصفيحه لان وهو بيتصل
بصدع البحر الميت هو صدر اغاني بيتحرك
بهذا الطريقه
صدع طويل جدا صدر
وعمق الزلازل في ممكن يكون بعمق 30 كم
اذا بتتحرك كله ممكن يولد لنا زلازل كثير
اكبر من يلي شفناه اذا لازم نمر ثمانيه او
ثمانيه ونصف وبالتالي بيكون التاثير كثيره
اضخم على الجوار وحتى على على الوسط
التركي والوسط السوري ممكن تاثيره رقم
ثمانيه ونص يمثل وعلى لبنان اذا سمحت
ليوني رئيس المعهد الوطني فيزياء
والبراكين تنقل عنه كوريا بانه بيعتقد
بانه الصفيحه الاناضوليه تلك تحركت ثلاثه
امتار على الاقل في الاتجاه الشمالي
الشرقي والجنوبي الغربي مقارنه بالصفيحه
العربيه
هل توافق على هذا الكلام يعني ثلاث امتار
شيء كبير جدا
درجه الزلزال كلمه هايلنا انه حركه الارض
كانت كثيره وبالتالي درجه زلزال 7.8 ممكن
كثير تخلي يعني جغرافيا نفسها بتكون تحرك
ثلاثه امتار ولا كيف ممكن نفهمها
الجغرافيا نفسها بتكون تحرك ثلاثه امتار
نعم اذا عندك تله قدامك ممكن تكون
ثلاثه امتار انت عندك بيت والفارق
فيه هذا البيت ينشقق القسمين ثلاثه امتار
بكل بساطه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور طوني نمره
الاستاذ والباحث في الجيولوجيا وعلم ازاله
في الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت
ومشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره حول زلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام ميسون تتابع معكم هذه التغطيه
اليها